like that let's do that Hey
sometimes when you peel off the foreskin
it could smell I love music have you
heard the new ariana grande CD
what baby do it oh did you say you get
this [ __ ] on it did you not yelling me
right now I am my middle school girls
soccer coach life's not exactly [ __ ]
roses right now okay Oh yell at me right
now you're looking at where I sleep
riverboats in that dog here we go this
is horrible wine it's why does it say
Chardonnay on it and it's right there's
a phone going I'm not gonna point you
out blonde lady over there but you
should probably turn it off
do you not gonna fix this [ __ ] like I
wish I could give you one now like just
go boom you're divorced
I shouldn't charge it for four hours
though cuz that that was some horrific
[ __ ] right there
I should be subjected to this I went to
school damn it I never want to see the
one you again not even sex once we read
about us ever walk well excuse me doctor
I've been here for like five minutes
gonna be lurch all over you
that's how I sound you [ __ ] you did
it last month Mike that's a long you did
it in front of Dillon who the [ __ ] is
different or it's horrific Wow clear hey
we need therapy honey what the hell